[Musica]
Cosa succede se il luogo privilegiato
dell'educazione quello che dovrebbe
fornirci gli strumenti per comprendere
la società che ci sta attorno non si
trova allineato con il mondo che lo
circonda Cosa succede se nel 2022 la
scuola fornisce i propri studenti i
mezzi di comprensione di un mondo che
fermo a 100 anni prima Beh succede che
la scuola perde il proprio senso diventa
inutile
provando ad indagare Le ragioni della
anacronismo della scuola italiana Ho
provato a pensare a qualcosa diciamo e
prima di gettarmi in un'impresa
nell'impresa di questo Talk vorrei però
partire da un po' più indietro prendiamo
il nostro vecchio manuale di storia
delle superiori lo spolveriamo e
sfogliamo un po' di pagine fino al 3
dicembre 1922 Jordan il quale l'allora
re d'Italia Vittorio Emanuele III di
Savoia affittua il governo la delega per
il rinnovo alla pubblica amministrazione
per convenzione Infatti con questa data
si fa coincidere il primo atto della più
fascista delle riforme Come disse Benito
Mussolini Ovvero la Riforma Gentile
Beh non è un caso il fatto che il
fascismo abbia fatto di questa riforma
il proprio manifesto culturale e vorrei
provare a dimostrarvelo con questa
citazione
occorre che intorno al fanciullo tutto
sia penetrato di sentimento gli ideali
fascisti che tutto nella scuola gli
parli di ciò che tutti i suoi pensieri
sulle atti sono ricondotti
dall'educatore a quei principi a quella
disciplina così che egli Naturalmente ne
contragga l'abito e lo porti con sé
nella casa dove aggira sugli altri per
benefico contagio
Queste erano le parole di Alberto
geremicca un deputato fascista che nel
1928 si esprimeva con queste parole
riguardo alla fascistizzazione della
scuola
Beh che dire il fascismo era convinto
che la scuola potesse essere il giusto
mezzo di diffusione della propria
filosofia politica e della propria
cultura dello stato solo così Infatti si
sarebbe potuto ottenere il completo
primato del pubblico sul privato e solo
partendo dalla scuola il fascismo la
religione politica dello Stato sarebbe
riuscito a compiere l'ambientamento
dell'individuo Lo scopo della Riforma
Gentile si sarebbe Dunque risolto ed in
gran parte si risolse nella fusione fra
l'idenità nazionale e quella fascista in
maniera tale che italiano e fascista non
di venissero altro che termini
sinonimici che non vi fosse più
differenza tra Italia è stato fascista
tutto questo per dirvi che cosa per
raccontarvi una sfida che ha a che fare
con questo concetto con il ribaltamento
di questo concetto e con il tentativo di
rimettere al centro dell'idea di scuola
quell'elemento che dalla scuola stessa
era stato in qualche modo escluso
adombrato messo da parte ovvero
l'individuo insieme ad altri tre
compagni del liceo Infatti l'anno scorso
sono diventato rappresentante d'istituto
e come penso fosse stata immaginare fra
esami di stato pandemia mascherine è
stato un anno particolarmente difficile
penso che non vi dovreste sforzare
troppo nell'immaginarlo sono successe
tantissime cose e vi vorrei parlare di
una di queste cose
sera del 6 dicembre 2021 per la prima
volta nella provincia di Varese per la
seconda volta in Lombardia al liceo
classico Ernesto Cairoli veniva
approvata la carriera alias Ora vorrei
interpellare un attimo lassale Vorrei
chiedere anche al sesso delle mani tutti
coloro che sappiano spiegare con
precisione Che cos'è la carriera Alias
vedo pochissime mani
e a beneficio di coloro che sono la
maggior parte che non sappiano che cos'è
la carriera alias essa è una tipologia
fondamentalmente attraverso il quale uno
studente può richiedere se maggiorenne
Oppure si minorenne con il consenso
firmato dei propri genitori l'attuazione
della propria del proprio nome di
lezione all'interno del contesto
scolastico Cosa significa significa che
lo studente trans che l'oggetto di
questo regolamento nel caso dopo aver
presentato una certificazione
psicologica che testi la propria
disforia di genere ovvero il mancato
riconoscimento del proprio sesso
biologico può richiedere in classe
l'utilizzo del proprio nome di lezione
del proprio nome di scelta la criminales
è il primo atto di riconoscimento della
comunità trans all'interno della della
scuola italiana ed esprimi un sole
semplicissime diritto quello di essere
se stessi e di essere riconosciuti come
tali se non fossimo qua su questo palco
lo chiameremo il principio di
autodeterminazione
il raggiungimento di questo obiettivo è
stato graduale
In primo luogo Abbiamo saldato
l'opinione degli altri studenti e i
risultati sono stati più che
soddisfacenti su 756 studenti iscritti
in 456 hanno espresso la loro opinione
i421 di questi favorevolmente a fronte
di un 7,9% di votanti contrari
forti di queste investitura Popolare
studentesca siamo riusciti ad affrontare
anche quelle posizioni di alcuni
professori che in consiglio d'istituto
si erano manifestati in maniera
contraria
forti di questa volontà Comune Quindi e
anche del sostegno di alcuni professori
in consiglio d'istituto siamo riusciti
ad ottenere un importantissima Vittoria
a me agli altri rappresentanti è stato
fin da subito chiaro e rivivere che
l'introduzione di questo regolamento
avrebbe significato più
che i singoli articoli che lo
componevano Ma avrebbe assolto ad una
duplice funzione
questi due funzioni mi piace chiamarle
Scusate il gioco di parole esclusiva ed
inclusiva la funzione esclusiva è
diretta esclusivamente agli studenti
trans anche senza che essi Infatti
decidono di richiedere l'attivazione
della creare alias azione per la quale
servirebbe un'esposizione pubblica per
la quale lo studente può non ancora
sentirsi pronto la carerai asse comunque
un atto di riconoscimento degli studenti
trans all'interno del contesto
scolastico gli fa sentire presenti li fa
sentire rappresentati la funzione
inclusiva Invece è quella che si pone
come obiettivo il tentativo di allargare
la comprensione che il travaglio della
scoperta della propria identità porta
con sé anche coloro che non hanno mai
vissuto o che mai vivranno una disforia
di genere
in questo senso Io credo che sia
importantissimo che sia necessario
riportare in Auge quel sistema di valori
che gli stati europei e che le
democrazie liberali hanno promosso dopo
la Seconda Guerra Mondiale dopo la
caduta di quegli stati che avevano
voluto e che avevano causato la guerra
questo sistema valoriale che è stato
garante di pace di diritti e dire che è
partorito dalla disgregazione del
nazismo del Fascismo nel dopoguerra si è
mosso fondamentalmente lungo due binari
quello dell'inclusione e quello
dell'equità
Se vogliamo che questo sistema valoriale
sopravviva
se crediamo che questi due presupposti
di nuovo
inclusione ed equità debbano essere la
premessa fondante anche nel nostro
sistema futuro noi dobbiamo lottare oggi
per questi valori dobbiamo lavorare oggi
per essi dobbiamo Insegnarle dobbiamo
dar loro voce
perché nessuno li difenderà se non
saremmo noi stessi a farlo perché
nessuno si iscriverà dal loro parte se
non saremo noi a difenderli noi che
godiamo del privilegio della democrazia
e del benessere che accompagna la
democrazia
io nel piccolo della mia scuola l'ho
provato a fare con queste diverse altri
gesti di cui oggi non vi ho parlato
Ma che viaggiano ugualmente in questa
direzione e non sono ancora sufficienti
quello che vi ho portato Spero possa
essere un esempio che ci ricordi ancora
una volta che la libertà è un lavoro
come tale di chi li impegno ricchi di
sacrificio il racconto che vi ho portato
oggi Spero possa ricordarci ancora una
volta che quei valori
democratici inclusione di equità sono la
testimonianza del sangue che è stato
versato per il loro ottenimento
che parte dalle nostre aule che porterà
i vostri studi dei vostri uffici non
importa
avere un desiderio per concludere vorrei
che oggi quando uscissimo da questa sala
tornassimo a casa con una sola e precise
idee in testa la democrazia non è un
regalo Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]